the Deluge tour through the coastal city
of Volos destroying homes businesses and
infrastructure
more than 250 people have been evacuated
from the city since storm Alias struck
on Wednesday causing the craftsydonas
river to burst its banks and plunging 80
percent of the city Into Darkness locals
are blaming poor planning for making
matters worse
we've been battling the situation with
the water for 20 days they do not come
to help us they open one small drain and
then they leave the rest
this was destined to happen up until
yesterday they were collecting heaps of
mud and they did not finish in time and
then this happened there was of course a
lot of water but they did not do their
jobs properly
extreme rainfall comes just three weeks
after devastating storm Daniel killed 16
people in The Wider region and follows a
summer of deadly wildfires
the Greek government this week declared
adapting to climate change and National
priority Eve Barker Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera